tous les moyens sont ils bons pour
améliorer la productivité agricole fin
des années 90 les organismes
génétiquement modifiés font leur
apparition en france sous forme de
céréales transformées un moyen de
produire plus pour ses partisans une
menace pour l'environnement pour ses
opposants
l'homme est il en train de jouer les
apprentis sorciers en 1997 deschamps
dauger m expérimentaux en plein air voit
le jour sur le sol français
la crainte des opposants qu'avec le vent
ces ogm se disséminent dans les
parcelles voisines alors leur réaction
ne se fait pas attendre
le fauchage je fais une bonne action
pourquoi pour l'avenir
ces militants s'appellent eux-mêmes les
faucheurs volontaires et deviendront le
symbole de la lutte anti ogm
un homme aussi sera le visage de cette
lutte josé bové
en 1998 il écope de 8 mois de sursis
pour avoir détruit du maïs transgénique
dans un dépôt de la société novartis
quelques mois après une étude
britannique révèle que les aliments
transgéniques sont nocifs pour les rats
et donc potentiellement pour l'homme
réaction de l'intéressé on a eu raison
parce qu'aujourd'hui ni les
consommateurs ni les paysans ne veulent
de gm
seules les multinationales essaye
d'imposer ces organismes parce que ça
leur rapporte beaucoup d'argent au
mépris de la santé humaine et animale
le combat des anti ogm va aller jusqu'à
la cour de justice européenne
ils sont entre autres défendu par
l'ancien ministre de l'environnement qui
avait réussi à interdire un temps les
ogm sur le sol français
c'est une question de fonctionnement de
l'europe et puis des pouvoirs des
multinationales agroalimentaires des
mères aussi s'oppose à la culture des
ogm sur le sol français
leurs moyens d'actions utilisé des
arrêtés pour faire interdire les champs
expérimentaux sur leur commune exemple
en normandie en 2010 je dis non parce
que il n'y a aucune certitude à l'heure
actuelle il ya plutôt des inquiétudes et
à partir du moment où lui à ces
inquiétudes jeu
je souhaite protéger ma population mais
en plus de lutter contre la culture des
ogm sur le sol français
les militants mais aussi des actions
pour dénoncer l'importation des céréales
transgéniques en france à l'image de
greenpeace en 2000 qui bloquent un
navire venu des états unis
comment déjà tranché mais aussi des
actions dans les grandes surfaces pour
dénoncer le manque de traçabilité et la
présence potentielle de gm dans la
viande nourris au soja importé la
culture des ogm à des fins commerciales
est interdite en france depuis 2008 et
depuis la loi de juin 2014
il est interdit de cultiver du maïs
transgénique même de façon expérimentale
mais les faucheurs n'ont pas dit leur
dernier mot
en janvier 2020 des militants de la
confédération paysanne dénonce et la
commercialisation produits leuze de
semences d'endives ogm
leur combat est loin d'être terminé
[Musique]